Es la idea de evitar la intervención de los políticos
y hacer que la gente vote directamente sobre los asuntos,
que vote las leyes directamente.
Pero esta idea es ingenua
porque hay demasiadas cosas que deberíamos elegir.
Si miran el 114° Congreso estadounidense
habrán visto que la Cámara de Representantes
examinó más de 6000 proyectos de ley,
el Senado examinó más de 3000,
y aprobaron más de 300 leyes.
Esas serían las muchas decisiones que cada persona debería tomar por semana
sobre temas que no son de su conocimiento.
Es decir, hay un gran problema de distancia cognitiva
si pensamos en la democracia directa como alternativa viable.
Algunas personas piensan en la idea de la democracia líquida o delegativa,
en la que se entrega el poder político a alguien
que pueda dárselo a alguien más,
y, con el tiempo, se crea una gran red de seguidores
en la que, al final, unas pocas personas toman las decisiones
en nombre de todos sus seguidores y los seguidores de estos.
Pero esta idea tampoco resuelve el problema cognitivo
y, para ser sincero, es bastante similar a la idea de tener un representante.
Lo que haré hoy es ser un poco provocativo,
y voy a preguntarles:
¿y si en vez de evitar a los políticos,
tratamos de automatizarlos?
La idea de automatización no es nueva.
Comenzó hace más de 300 años,
cuando tejedores franceses decidieron automatizar el telar.
El ganador de esa guerra industrial fue Joseph-Marie Jacquard.
Fue un tejedor y vendedor francés
que combinó el telar con la máquina de vapor para crear telares autónomos.
Y con esos telares autónomos logró tener el control.
Ahora podía hacer telas que eran más complejas y sofisticadas
que las que podían hacer a mano.
Pero además, al ganar esa guerra industrial,
sentó la base de lo que se convirtió en el modelo de la automatización.
La manera en que automatizamos las cosas en los últimos 300 años
siempre ha sido la misma:
primero, identificamos una necesidad,
después creamos una herramienta para satisfacer esa necesidad,
como el telar, en este caso,
y luego estudiamos cómo la gente utiliza esa herramienta
para automatizar a ese usuario.
Así pasamos del telar mecánico al telar autónomo,
y eso nos llevó mil años.
Ahora, solo nos llevó cien años
usar el mismo guion para automatizar el coche.
La cuestión es que, en esta ocasión,
la automatización es real.
Este es un video que un colega de Toshiba compartió conmigo
de la fábrica que elabora unidades de estado sólido.
La fábrica entera es un robot.
No hay humanos en esa fábrica.
Y pronto, los robots dejarán las fábricas
y serán parte de nuestro mundo, parte de nuestra fuerza laboral.
Lo que hago diariamente en mi trabajo
es crear herramientas que integran información para países enteros
para que finalmente podamos tener los cimientos que necesitamos
para un futuro en el que necesitemos manejar esas máquinas.
Pero hoy no estoy aquí para hablarles de estas herramientas
que integran información para los países,
sino para hablarles de otra idea
que puede ayudarnos a usar inteligencia artificial en la democracia.
Porque las herramientas que hago están diseñadas para decisiones ejecutivas
y estas decisiones pueden encasillarse en algún tipo de término de objetividad:
decisiones de inversión pública.
Pero hay decisiones legislativas,
y estas decisiones legislativas requieren comunicación entre las personas
que tienen distintos puntos de vista,
requieren participación, debate, deliberación.
Y durante mucho tiempo pensamos
que lo necesario para mejorar la democracia es más comunicación.
Todas las tecnologías que desarrollamos en el contexto de la democracia,
ya sea en los periódicos o en las redes sociales,
trataron de brindarnos más comunicación.
Pero ya hemos caído en esa trampa, y sabemos que no resuelve el problema.
Porque no es un problema de comunicación, sino un problema de distancia cognitiva.
Si el problema es cognitivo,
agregar más comunicación no será la solución.
En cambio, lo que necesitaremos es tener otras tecnologías
que nos ayuden a manejar la comunicación que tenemos en exceso.
Piensen en un pequeño avatar,
un agente de software,
un Pepito Grillo digital,
(Risas)
que básicamente puede responder cosas por ti.
Y si tuviéramos esa tecnología,
podríamos descargar parte de la comunicación
y ayudar, tal vez, a tomar mejores decisiones, o a mayor escala.
La cuestión es que la idea de agentes de software tampoco es nueva.
Ya la usamos todo el tiempo.
Usamos agentes de software
para saber cómo llegar a cierto lugar,
qué música vamos a escuchar
o para recibir sugerencias de los próximos libros que deberíamos leer.
Hay una idea obvia en el siglo XXI
que fue tan obvia como la idea
de combinar una máquina de vapor con un telar en la época de Jacquard.
Y esa idea es combinar la democracia directa con agentes de software.
Imaginen, por un segundo, un mundo donde, en vez de tener un representante
que los represente a ustedes y a millones de otras personas,
pueden tener un representante que solo los represente a Uds.
con sus opiniones políticas diferentes,
esa rara combinación de libertario y liberal
y tal vez un poco conservador en algunos asuntos,
y muy progresista en otros.
Hoy en día, los políticos son paquetes, y están llenos de compromisos.
Pero pueden tener a alguien que los represente solo a Uds.
si están dispuestos a abandonar la idea de que ese representante sea un humano.
Si ese representante es un agente de software,
podríamos tener un senado que tenga tantos senadores como ciudadanos.
Y esos senadores podrán leer cada proyecto de ley,
y podrán votar por cada uno de ellos.
Hay una idea obvia, entonces, que tal vez debamos considerar.
Pero entiendo que en esta época, esta idea puede ser alarmante.
De hecho, pensar en un robot que venga del futuro
para ayudarnos a gobernar suena aterrador.
Pero ya lo hemos hecho.
(Risas)
Y de hecho era un buen tipo.
¿Cómo se vería la versión del telar de Jacquard en esta idea?
Sería un sistema muy simple.
Imaginen un sistema en el que inician sesión y crean un avatar,
y luego comienzan a entrenar su avatar.
Podemos dotar nuestro avatar con nuestros hábitos de lectura,
o conectarlo a nuestras redes sociales,
o conectarlo a otra información,
por ejemplo mediante pruebas psicológicas.
Y lo bueno de esto es que no hay engaño.
No proporcionan información para comunicarse con sus amigos y familia
que luego se utiliza en un sistema político.
Proporciona información a un sistema que está diseñado para ser utilizado
para tomar decisiones políticas en nuestro nombre.
Luego, toma esa información y elige un algoritmo de entrenamiento,
porque es un mercado abierto
en el que diferentes personas pueden presentar distintos algoritmos
para predecir cómo votarán, basándose en la información que proporcionaron.
Y el sistema es abierto. Nadie controla los algoritmos.
Hay algoritmos que se hacen más populares y otros no tanto.
Con el tiempo, se puede auditar el sistema.
Pueden ver cómo funciona su avatar, y dejarlo en piloto automático si quieren.
Si quieren controlar un poco más,
pueden elegir que les consulte cuando toma una decisión,
o puede estar entre esas opciones.
Una de las razones por las que usamos tan poco la democracia
puede ser porque la democracia tiene una interfaz de usuario muy mala.
Si mejoramos la interfaz de usuario de la democracia,
podríamos utilizarla más.
Claro, hay muchas preguntas que pueden surgir.
Por ejemplo, ¿cómo entrenar a esos avatares?
¿Cómo mantener segura la información?
¿Cómo mantener los sistemas distribuidos y auditables?
¿Cómo hace mi abuela, que tiene 80 años y no sabe usar internet?
Créanme, las escuché a todas.
Cuando piensan en una idea como esta, tengan cuidado con los pesimistas
porque suelen tener un problema para cada solución.
(Risas)
Quiero invitarlos a pensar en las ideas más grandes.
Las preguntas que acabo de mostrarles son pequeñas ideas
porque son preguntas sobre cómo esto no funcionaría.
Las grandes ideas son ideas sobre qué más podemos hacer con esto
si funcionara.
Y una de esas ideas es: ¿quién redacta las leyes?
Al principio, podíamos hacer que los avatares que ya tenemos
voten leyes que están redactadas por los senadores o los políticos
que ya tenemos.
Pero si esto funcionara,
podrían crear un algoritmo que intente redactar una ley
que obtendría un cierto porcentaje de aprobación,
y pueden revertir el proceso.
Ahora bien, pueden pensar que es una idea absurda y no deberíamos hacerlo,
pero no pueden negar que esta idea solo es posible
en un mundo donde la democracia directa y los agentes de software
son una forma viable de participación.
Pues bien, ¿cómo empezamos la revolución?
No se empieza esta revolución con vallas de contención o protestas,
ni exigiendo que nuestros actuales políticos se cambien por robots.
No funcionará.
Esto es mucho más sencillo, más lento y mucho más humilde.
Esta revolución empieza creando sistemas simples
en escuelas de posgrado, en bibliotecas y en ONG.
Y tratamos de descifrar todas esas pequeñas preguntas
y esos pequeños problemas
que tendremos que resolver para hacer esta idea viable,
para hacer de esta idea algo confiable.
Y al crear esos sistemas que permiten a cientos o miles de personas,
a cien mil personas votar de manera políticamente no obligatoria,
esta idea irá sumando confianza, el mundo cambiará,
y quienes ahora son tan pequeños como mi hija, van a crecer.
Y para cuando mi hija tenga mi edad,
tal vez esta idea que hoy parece tan absurda
no sea absurda para ella y sus amigos.
Y en ese momento,
estaremos al final de nuestra historia, pero ellos estarán al comienzo de la suya.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)